من تل ابيب الدكتور دان شيفتان رئيس
برنامج الدراسات العليا الدوليه في دراسات
الامن القومي في جامعه حيفا
وكذلك معنا ايضا من القدس الدكتور احمد
الطيبي النائب في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
ورئيس الحركه العربيه للتغيير اهلا بكم
وابدا معك دكتور دان شفتان ما هي الحاجه
التي استدعت وتستدعي تشكيله مثل هذه
القوات الحرس الوطني رغم كل المعارضه
والجدل القائم في اسرائيل حيلها
هذا خطا كبير تاسيس هذه القوه هناك ضروره
لحرس وطني في اسرائيل لان لدينا مشكله
كبيره بما بذلك ما بين المواطنين العرب من
اسرائيل وكما شاهدنا في عام 2021 في المدن
المختلطه ولكن لا اعتقد ان ما يقوم به هو
امر غير شرعي وغير قانوني ووعد انما قررت
الحكومه اليوم هو خطا وهذا لا يتحقق من
ناحيه العمليه الكل كل ما في اسرائيل ضد
هذه الخطوه لن تتحقق وفي نهايه المطاف
هناك مؤسسه وهيئه تحت سيطره القوه الشرطه
في اسرائيل وكما قال ابن كثير هو مستعد
ذلك ولا بقبول ذلك لكن عن ذلك سيتحقق
اعتقد ان هذا خطا رئيسي كبير وحتى موضوع
طرح هذا الفكره حتى طرح الفكره خطا لكن
كيف يعني تقول بانها لن تتحقق من اي منطلق
لن تتحقق مثل هذه الخطوه سيد دان
الامن الداخلي ايضا ضد هذه الفكره
وان المؤسسه القضائيه ايضا ضد هذه الفكره
لا ليس هناك اي شخص يريد ان تحصل مثل هذا
الشيء تحت قياده حاليا
الشرط رغم انه لا يغادر هذا الائتلاف
فبالتالي قدم هذا الاقتراح لاسباب سياسيه
انا افهم دوافعها واعتقد ايضا ان هذا خطا
سياسي ليس ايضا خطا سياسي لانه لا يمكن
تاسيسه منظمه في اسرائيل ذو ازاءه معارضه
كل المؤسسه الدفاعيه في البلاد الدكتور
احمد الطيب يعني هي خطا كبير كما وصفها
دكتور تاء دان وخطا سياسي وقال بانها لن
تتحقق ما هي بمنظورك يعني قراءتك لتشكيل
مثل هذه القوات لهذه الخطوه ما المغزى
والغرض من تشكيل مثل هذه القوات الان
هي خطا
وخطاير الذي تسلم منصبه كوزير للامن
الداخلي وزير الامن القومي حتى اليوم فشل
في هذا المنصب اسرائيليا هو فشل ولذلك هو
بحاجه الى انجاز ولو اعلامي او ما يتخطى
ذلك
ليغطي على هذا الفشل ولذلك استغل ازمه
التشريعات القانونيه ورغبه نتنياهو في
تعليق هذه التشريعات
ليبتز من نتنياهو الذي يسهل الابتزاز في
هذا الائتلاف من كل حزب ائتلافي
قرارا باقامه هذه الميليشيا الخاصه بب
الحقيقه ان القرار باقامه
هذه هذه القوات كان بفتره حكم نفتالي بنت
وكان يقصد توسيع حرس الحدود وهي قوه قائمه
نفس الاهداف يقوم بها حرس الحدود التدخل
السريع فض المظاهرات الى اخره وهي قوه
عدوانيه عدوانيه هرس الحدود قوه عدوانيه
خاصه تجاه العرب وفي الاراضي المحتله ايضا
في المدن العربيه وغيرها وهكذا كانت فيها
ايار ولكن هناك صعوبه في اخراج هذه الفكره
الى حيز التمثيل نظرا لمعارضه كما قال
الدكتور شفتان كل ان اجهزه الامنيه في
اسرائيل والمستشاره القضائيه
للحكومه
تنفيذها دكتور احمد الطيبي السؤال الى
الدكتور دان يعني رغم ما تقوله او يعني
اتفقتم كلاهما على ان هذه الخطوه قد تكون
صعبه التنفيذ او التحقيق على ارض الواقع
لكن اني يوافق عليها رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو
على خطوه من هذا النوع لوزير امنه الداخلي
بنك من يقود هذه الحكومه دكتور دان لمن
اليد الطوله والكلمه الفاصل في هذه
الحكومه
اتفق مع الدكتور احمد الطيبي واعتقد اتفاق
لمره واحده فقط اعتقد الرئيس الوزراء قد
فقد
نظرته للحكم والحكومه وقد اثبت بانه ليس
فقط ليس بصحه جيده كرئيس وزراعه نحقق
اهداف وطنيه قوميه لكنه ايضا يؤثر على
موقفه السياسي باتخاذ قرارات يتخذها اولا
بما يتعلق بموقفه ازاء الاصلاحات القضائيه
ورد فعله وكان قليلا ومتاخرا والان بن
غدير مستعد يقوم بكل شيء ليبقى على نفسه
في السلطه واعتقد ان هذا يبين انما جعله
نسبيا رئيس جيد في السابق كل هذه السنوات
قد انتهت وهذا انتهى الامر وهذه بدايه
نهايه
سيطرته على النظام السياسي
في اسرائيل
قراءه توجهات الحكومه الان خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بفلسطينيه الداخل ما الذي يمكن ان
ينعكس او تكون من تداعيات مثل خطوات من
هذا النوع
العنصريه كانت طيارا مركزيا في العقود
الاخيره في المجتمع الاسرائيلي الان
الفاشيه اصبحت طيارا رسميا في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بين وغيرهم في كمان وزراء من
الليكود اللي هم
يؤمنون بنظريات عنصريه وفاشيه ولكن تحديدا
بين الذي ابتزن نتنياهو نتنياهو في موقف
يسهل او يمكن لكل حزب الى فيه ان
يبتزهير هددوا بالخروج من الائتلاف قبل
اسبوعين ولذلك وقع له على ورقه هذه
الميليشيا اللي بنقدر يريدها ان تشبه قوه
فاجنر في روسيا ميليشيا ميليشيا من زعران
اليمين
ومجموعه لافاميليا العنصريه وهو يستهدف
الفلسطينيين في المدن المختلطه اساسا او
ربما سيستعملها ضد المتظاهرين من المركز
واليسار اللي يتظاهروا في الشوارع ولكن
انا اتعامل معها وكانها
ستخرج الى حيز التنفيذ غدا مع انه في هناك
صعوبات الى اخراجها الى حيز التنفيذ وهكذا
يجب ان نتعامل معها جميعا وكانها خطر داهم
ولكن هذا مؤشر على ان هذه الحكومه اللي
فيها وزير يقول يجب ان نمحو حوارا
وشرطه تاكل تقتل شهيدا من حوره
هذه الحكومه فاشيه
وصلت الفكره دكتور احمد الطيبي النائب في
الكنيسه الاسرائيليه ورئيس الحركه العربيه
للتغيير اشكرك من القدس والدكتور دانشفان
رئيس برنامج الدراسات العليا الدوليه من
تل ابيب شكرا جزيلا لكم